was a nation and i love you guys to
death i think there are some times where
you put me on a pedestal like i
i am i am something that i am not you
don't even mean like i am very flawed um
and i and i work at it you know what i
mean um and i fail a lot and ego has
been one that i have struggled a lot
with and it was the thing that really
isolated me you know when i was younger
uh because i definitely you know and i
think ego is another way of saying
insecurity um of just you know wanting
to prove that you're better than people
because deep down you don't feel like
you're good enough i recently i think in
my own by my own terms uh bombed a
couple interviews
and
it's been a kind of rough 24 hours for
me
and i honestly would had never had any
intention of making a video about it
but layla was like i think you should
share this stuff with the audience
because they will probably benefit from
it so here i am so i am feeling uh not a
hundred percent uh to be transparent
with you
um and i honestly just felt like i got
kicked in the nuts the last uh last day
or so
and uh it happened because um layla and
i did an interview um with ryan pineda
on his podcast and um after
after getting off the
interview uh you know layla when we were
walking around our our daily loop she
was like hey um
are you trying to come off a certain way
and uh i just kind of looked at her as
like i mean not consciously why she's
like well
you're
you're coming off like ultra analytical
and uh
not um like as fun
and i was like well that's not you know
my hope and she didn't say it but i
think part of it was also like and
probably a little prideful
um and i was like well that sucks and
like i take layla's feedback more
seriously than just about anybody
because
i know she has no
i trust her intentions you know most
people have an ulterior motive which is
one of those difficult things in terms
of like who do you trust for feedback
um
but i trust my wife's motives that she
just wants me you know to be better and
she said hey to be clear if that's what
you want then then i'm not saying it's
bad you know i accept whatever you want
i just i don't know if that's what your
intention is
and so um i was pretty quiet for the
rest of the walk home and just really
kind of kept mulling on it it did bug me
a lot because
one of the things that scares me is when
i'm you know coming off in a way that
i'm not aware of you know what i mean
and so it feels like a blind spot and it
just it feels very out of control for
lack of a better term and so
anyways that was uh pretty you know not
fun and then this morning i got a
message from um
our team that edits the the podcasts for
us
um
and he was like hey and i had done a
podcast yesterday as well so i did two
podcasts yesterday um
and i did a spartan up podcast um
and uh on that podcast
i don't know it just i i wasn't joe and
i were not vibing or at least i didn't
think we were um and uh i think i came
off like a little bit of a douchebag
and i i felt like it was off even during
the podcast
um
but anyways when my podcast editor this
morning came up because he like saw the
the the footage
um
he was like you know and
he's trying to do this as like
tastefully as he possibly can
um
for lack of a term he was like you know
you kind of sound like a dick
um and uh you're
you know it sounds condescending and
you're talking above the audience you're
not really serving anyone
and that was that one really kind of
like drilled me in the nuts because it
was right after i heard it from layla
and heard it from him and so in a lot of
ways i would say i'm grateful that
that happened uh because you know if
layla had just said it i think i would
have you know i'd take it seriously but
like two people in 24 hours saying it
made me really think
uh long and hard about it because um
you know just very transparently like
the number one thing i've struggled with
my entire life is ego um
and it's a topic that i don't know i
feel like it gets talked a lot more in
the woo world than it does in like the
entrepreneur world but you know i think
like ego kills profits ego
pride kills profits that's a that's a
much more quotable uh thing uh so pride
pride kills profits and a lot of it is
because like we care more about being
right than serving the other person
and there's this quote about humility
that um shoot i can't remember the guy's
name but um he's the guy who wrote uh
i think disruptive innovation he was a
harvard business school professor i
think his first name is christian
anyways very very smart guy um and he
said humility is not thinking less of
oneself but increasing your regard for
others
and that was a really useful definition
for me because it's you know it's not
about pushing yourself down it's about
raising everyone else up and i think
that
um there's been some podcasts that have
gone really well like there's a school
of greatness podcast with louis house
that i think is really really good
that's going to come out soon um there's
a podcast
the iced coffee hour podcast with graham
stefan and jack selby on their channel
which you can check out is i think a
really good podcast at least i've gotten
a lot of positive feedback from it
and i was trying to look at like what's
the difference between those ones and
the ones that i come off
you know douchier and you know i'm
partially exploring this out live with
you guys because like i don't know if
there's times where you're you know not
coming off the way you want to or you're
like not in the right mood or you're
just you're not the best version of you
you know what i mean and i i'm kind of
making this because
i think you know i i feel like just from
the comments and the posts and the tags
and things like that like who's the
nation and i love you guys to death i
think there are some times where you put
me on a pedestal like i
i am i am something that i am not you
don't mean like i am very flawed um and
i and i work at it you know what i mean
um and i fail a lot
and ego has been one that i've struggled
a lot with and it was the thing that
really isolated me you know when i was
younger uh because i definitely you know
and i think ego is another way of saying
insecurity
of just you know wanting to prove that
you're better than people because deep
down you don't feel like you're good
enough and so
for me uh that's been a struggle my
entire life and it's been just a i see
it much more as a war than i do a a
battle you know what i mean so you know
wars have many many battles in them and
at this point i'm definitely not
undefeated so it's much more about like
i'd like to have more w's than l's uh in
the in the wins and losses column around
this and i think i've just had a lot of
l's lately
and so
i'll just explain to you what i think
you know my process of what i'm going to
try and think of around this you know in
the future is that um i'm going to try
and
level set before i get on interviews
and so i put a little checklist in my
phone of like hey humility is increasing
your regard for others it's caring more
about the audience it's caring more
about the other person than being right
um
and uh and it's it's it's ideally just
lifting up everyone around you
and it's just you know i think there's
just this part of me that
always screams out and wants to you know
prove something and i'm sure that you
know a lot of the material success has
come from this place and i don't think
it's a positive place i think it's a
negative one um
or rather it's a you know an emotion
that that i wouldn't say is a pool it's
a when i see positive negative i should
redefine it as it is an away from fuel
rather than a towards fuel like most of
my motivation has been trying not to
feel like a failure
in my own eyes
than it is to you know pull towards
something i'd like to when i operate in
my best self i think i have more pool
motivation but i still think that
there's a significant part of me that is
driven away from things and driven away
from pain
and so um i noticed the common theme
between the ones that i did well on and
the ones that i didn't do you know or
didn't show up the way i wanted to
was um i think my ego flared up and i
think that for me was
if i if i sense you know a more serious
you know tone from the other person or i
feel like i can't relax then um
then i then i don't you know what i mean
and i get hyper analytical and i get
really cold and so in some ways i think
my worst self is just kind of a light
version of anger um because i think
pride pride creates anger a lot of times
you know i mean it creates fear and then
that fear turns into anger uh you know
in the words of yoda and so um
being being cognizant of that uh is you
know at least at least now i'm sort of
aware of it and so i'm i'm making an
extra effort uh to not be that way and
to take steps beforehand where if i like
feel my ego flaring up
and trying to posture and trying to
prove right which is kind of when i get
into that that mode
uh i just get hyper analytical i get
really really
i don't know if defensive is the right
word but like
i really start defending all my ideas
and attacking other people's ideas um
and i just don't think it's helpful for
anyone you know what i mean and it
doesn't serve me
and so um
being transparent that is what i'm uh
you know working on right now in an
effort to make better stuff for you guys
uh because i
want to ideally suck less in the future
than i do today uh definitely feel
pretty shitty uh about it uh but i will
uh endeavor to be better and so uh my
steps and the kind of like the refrain
that i'm going back to is that humility
is about increasing my regard for others
it's about listening more it's about
seeking to understand not to prove right
um it's about trying to put the needs of
the audience first and um you know one
of the interesting things too is i feel
like i do better with lives so like if
i'm if i'm like on stage or like at
workshops or even doing like the
instagram live that i did the other day
like i feel like i i'm better when i'm
with you guys uh than when i do in a
recorded fashion like this
um
and i think even the podcasts that are
more recorded if like i might try and
incorporate more lives almost as a
crutch
to try and give myself a bridge to being
better about this
but i feel like if you guys are there
with me i feel much more like aware that
you guys are there and i want to make it
worth your time and worth your attention
and worth the cost um
but when you're not uh you know
sometimes i think i retreat into like my
more analytical side uh that tries to
just defend stuff and i i don't like it
so i'll give you a quick tangent on this
pride isolates us it makes us feel alone
and a lot of that i think also comes
from shame which is that we we feel
ashamed of things that we have done or
things that we have thought and we think
about what other people would say
about us and you know the reality is
that most people aren't even going to
show up to your funeral so why would you
care about what they're gonna say while
you're alive
um but we still do you know what i mean
because uh
social dynamics are a strong part of you
know tribe behavior and you know if you
get shunned by the tribe it feels like
death and so
it makes sense that we would we would
care about what other people think
because that is how we are raised like
that is how we learn behaviors that's
how we learn what's socially acceptable
et cetera you know to function as a
human being in society and so to say
like we're not going to care about what
other people think i think it's a
process that we try and unlearn over
time
but i don't think we ever get rid of it
because i think it's really just being
able to add an extra step or an extra
second of pause saying like i do care
about some things but
do i care about everything that society
thinks and so i think it's really being
more selective about the things that we
choose
to agree with or disagree with society
on
overall when it comes to how we judge
ourselves
but shape isolates us and so my my hope
and my experience has been
every time that i've kind of like shared
a secret or shared something that i was
ashamed of i realized that my fear of
the light
of it getting exposed was far greater
than the
the pain of exposing it to begin with
and so there's a thing i think there's a
saying it says uh shame cannot exist in
the light so shame only exists in
darkness which exists in isolation and
our pride
isolates us from other people and makes
us feel like we can't share those things
because we will you know be less than
and so
my goal is to die with no secrets so
that you know at least in my mind
everyone sees me for who i am because i
think the fear is if people saw the
aspects of yourself that you are not
proud of that they would think less of
you or they would reject you or not
approve of you
um or you would lose whatever you know
status that you have
and so i um i'm actively trying to
combat that so hopefully when i die uh i
will have no secrets left and everyone
who is around me knows those things and
accepts me for who i am including the
many flaws that exist within me so
anyways mosey nation i love you guys you
know this this audience that you know
you guys coming together has been
something that i i it was beyond what i
expected um it's certainly more than i
deserve um and i'm just i'm truly
grateful and uh you guys helped me be a
better version of me and so um i just
wanna say thank you and uh if you're new
to the channel hit subscribe if you
found this valuable and uh you know hate
it if you also found it not valuable
so anyways um have an amazing day guys
uh if you are new there's a whole bunch
of other stuff that's much more business
focused on this channel but i was
feeling rather in the dumps um and layla
said you should tell people about it so
here i am um so lots of love and i'll
see you guys the next fit bye